hi Albert my name is grown yeah and this
is Jennifer from Ireland and we're just
wondering what your current projects at
the moment and what have you doing since
he won the prize okay so lot of thing to
you to say because the discovery of the
jia ma which has been awarded by the
price actually take girls it was my new
field of science which is called spin
tonics and spintronics two days
expanding many very promising and
fascinating the action so i walk for
example on the spin class fare spin
transfer and i work in particular on the
application and spin transferred to the
design of new tape new new types of
oscillator for telecommunications by far
from the technology aloud 'is generation
of microwaves i am working also on the
carbon nanotubes and on other
carbon-based material like graphene we
are very promising for the future of
electronica spintronics i am working
also on new compounds with oxide new
type of two-dimensional electron gas at
the interface between oxide this is so
is there a lot of thing to do and i am
very pleasant to buy the development of
all these new directions my tonics